[Music]
many of The Lord of the Rings fans were
taken by surprise When The War of the
rerum was announced as an animated film
besides Euphoria there was also a big
amount of skepticism regarding the movie
which takes place about 260 years before
fero's journey to Mount Doom as the name
the war of the rerum suggests this time
the focus is on a very specific group of
people the inhabitants of Rohan who
already played a particular role in The
Two Towers the prideful Horsemen have
surely left a lasting impression on many
which makes the story about their
background all the more exciting one
more reason for us to take a more
in-depth look at all the current facts
about the production and the plot and
while not all of you are anime fans it
seems that something very special is
waiting for us this
time ever since the Amazon series The
Rings of power if not earlier we have
known about the great significance of
the ages in tolken World while the first
age ends with the defeat of margoth the
series is set in the second age which
concludes with the apparent demise of
Sauron the war of the rerum is now set
at a very particular time in in the
third age more precisely in the year
2758 exactly 260 years before Gandalf
sends Frodo on his way with the ring
this is called the time of The Long
Winter because Rohan was completely snow
covered for more than 5 months the
makers of the movie obviously rely even
more on references to the Norse
mythology here after all Rohan was
already strongly reminiscent of Viking
culture in the old
movies the new Lord of the Rings movie
is about the big conflict between the
roham and the dunlendings so here's a
quick summary of the meaning of these
names the roham also known as the riters
of Rohan are proud people of humans
living in the region of Rohan their
history dates back to the first age of
Middle Earth they originally descended
from The northmen Who eventually settled
in the area that would eventually become
Rohan the rerum are famous for their
horsemanship and their deeply
established horse culture horses are of
crucial importance to them and the
connection between people and horses is
a central part of their lives they breed
and care for horses that are
particularly suitable for war the
Society of the rerum is divided into
several King OMS with the king of Rohan
being the supreme ruler the capital of
Rohan is idoris where the golden Hall of
meduseld is situated the king seat the
roham are also known for their love of
poetry and their people's ancient
language the dun Lings were originally a
tribe of people who lived in the western
parts of Rohan before the Roho moved
into the region the dun Lings enjoyed a
long history and culture before they
were displaced by the Roho this led to a
strong enmity between the two peoples
the dun Lings lived mainly from
livestock and agriculture and were
widely known as herdsmen their Community
was organized into tribes and they had
their own deities and Customs the
conflict between the dun Lings and the
rerum lasted for centuries the rerum
eventually conquered the lands of the
duning and forced them into the
mountains of dunland this led to deep
resentment and mistrust between the two
peoples so it's not surprising that they
sided with Saron during the events of
the Lord of the Rings
trilogy as with most stories from Middle
Earth the general story lines are
already known from token's books it
remains to be seen whether the Creator
will fully stick to them and which
details will be added that have not been
mentioned yet roughly the story of the
war of the reram is about the following
the film is said at a time when the
realm of Rohan is again in an intense
conflict with the dun Lings Helm
hammerhand is the ninth king of Rohan
King FRA the leader of the dun Lings
challenges Helm to marry his daughter
Hera to his son wolf an insult that
ultimately leads to a disastrous war
between the two clans during this
dramatic confrontation a stronghold
plays a pivotal role that fans of The
Lord of the Rings are sure to be very
familiar with Helms Deep the scene in an
epic battle in The Two Towers however
this film does not only put emphasis on
the two kings the spotlight is also on
their offspring on the one hand there's
the brave princess Hera who grows up in
the midst of war and becomes a Fearless
Warrior on the other hand there's Wolf
the heir to the throne of dunland
muscular armed with an axe and with a
scarred face he is the main villain of
the film The First scenes from the film
were already presented at the film
festival ansy France this past June as a
result some details about the war of the
herum are known already the movie delves
deeper into the culture of the
Horseman's people which is mainly
centered on Warfare family power
structures and conflicts are at the
center of the plot with honor and
loyalty seen as being more important
than wealth and physical possessions in
addition the movie also promises to tell
Supernatural ghost stories a theme that
can fully utilize the possibilities of
Animation concept drawings published so
far also show impressive depictions of
olant and Orcs in the thick of battle
the images released so far definitely
make us eager for more and suggest a
dark and serious story in the finished
film we can presumably look forward to
seeing spectacular scenes and a more
in-depth portrayal of token's
world the female lead of the movie will
be Hera she's the daughter of Helma
hammerhand she was not named in token's
writings so her character is entirely
the work of the film's authors by them
however she's neither described as a
warrior princess nor as a princess in
distress her main task will be to show
the audience Middle Earth from a woman's
perspective the first comments about
Hera describe her as vulnerable able and
wild a somewhat boyish character she has
red hair and an untidy braid wears
leather armor and wields a sword Gaia
wise will provide the voice of the
princess who is the daughter of actress
Emma
Thompson her father Helm hammerhand was
the ninth king of Rohan he got his name
hammerhand because of a legendary action
that we will probably get to see in the
new movie Helm is above all a very
ferocious Warrior dreaded by his enemies
and regarded as invulnerable after all
his deeds have gone down in history it's
not a coincidence that the Fortress
Helms Deep is named after him the king
is dubbed by Hollywood star Brian Cox he
is experienced in the role of a
patriarch for example as the head of the
family in the hit series succession or
as king Agamemnon in
Troy the counterpart to Hera is Wolf the
King's son travels through dunland
always looking out for allies in the
fight against Rohan he is a tall buff
guy with long ruffled hair armed with an
axe and covered in Furs and a torn cloak
a scar above his eye makes him look like
a true Barbarian wolf is voed by Luke
pasqualino who most of you will know
from the Netflix series Shadow and
Bone fra Wolf's father will also have an
important role in the story not only is
he powerful but he's also Rich owning
many lands by the Adorn the river that
runs through Rohan he also claims to be
of noble descent from dunland which will
prove to be of great importance later in
the plot fra is dubbed by Shawn douly
whose voice we know from the video game
Elden
ring the last character worth knowing is
fof he is the nephew of Helm hammerhand
during the war he mainly stays in the
mountain fastness dun hero which similar
to Helms Deep is considered impregnable
we don't know how he will enter in the
events yet his voice will be provided by
a Hollywood newcomer namely Lawrence
ubong
Williams for the movie The War of the
roero new line Cinema and Warner
Brothers animation are in charge of the
production the project has already been
in the making for almost 2 years and
holds the promise of winning the hearts
of fans this is because as the creative
direction is in the hands of the highly
respected anime director Kenji kamama
who is most associated with cult anime
such as Ghost in the Shell and Ultram
man kamiyama has also made a name for
himself at Warner Brothers before where
he created the thrilling anime series
Blade Runner Black Lotus the first
people to talk about the new Lord of the
Rings movie are already stating that the
animation is very reminiscent of the
anime from the 9s but don't worry the
magical Spirit of the earlier Lord of
the Rings films will probably remain in
this new work as well Peter Jackson's
iconic visions as a significant
inspirational source for countless
scenes in the upcoming film according to
the makers the challenge was to convert
the world and characters into an
animated style without losing the charm
of the original films Daniel Faulkner
the art director of the movies was
instrumental in achieving this goal
together with the creative team he
immersed himself in the archives to find
the familiar models from the past films
and further shape them unfortunately we
haven't been able to watch a trailer or
teaser yet but there is still some time
until the movie release anyway it was
recently postponed from April to the end
of next year now the Lord of the Rings
The War of the rerum is scheduled to hit
theaters on December 13th
2024 what are your thoughts is a Lord of
the Rings anime a welcome change or are
you generally fed up with further
projects in tolken world and if you
could wish for your own spin-off what
would it be about as always we
appreciate the thumbs up and exciting
discussions below the video see you next
time
[Music]